Une année se passe et toujours rien.
Un jour, un homme bien mis s'approche de lui
et lui propose de lui offrir le déjeuner,
puis le dîner, puis le petit-déjeuner.
Il rencontre alors ce groupe de personnes dynamiques
qui l'aide à s'en sortir.
On lui donne un peu d’argent
pour s’acheter de nouveaux vêtements,
de l’argent à envoyer à sa famille au pays.
On le présente à une jeune femme.
Il finit par se marier.
Il commence une nouvelle vie.
Il a enfin un but dans la vie.
Puis un beau jour à Mogadiscio,
sous un ciel d’un bleu d’azur,
une voiture piégée explose.
Le gamin du village qui rêvait de la grande ville
était le kamikaze responsable de cet acte,
et ce groupe de gens plein de dynamisme
c’était al-Shabaab, une organisation terroriste
liée au groupe al-Qaeda.
Alors, comment se fait-il qu’un petit villageois
qui cherche seulement à réussir dans la grande ville
finisse par se faire exploser ?
Il était en train d’attendre.
En train d’attendre une opportunité,
en train d’attendre de construire son avenir,
en train d’attendre de trouver une issue,
et ce fut la première chose qui se présenta.
Ce fut la première chose qui le sortit
de ce que nous appellerons sa situation d’attente.
Et son histoire se répète
dans les centres urbains à travers le monde.
C’est l’histoire de la jeunesse urbaine,
sans emploi et marginalisée,
celle qui déclenche des émeutes à Johannesburg,
des émeutes à Londres,
celle qui tente de s’extraire de cette situation d’attente.
Pour les jeunes, la promesse de la grande ville,
le rêve de la grande ville est celui des opportunités,
du travail, de la richesse,
mais les jeunes ne profitent pas de la prospérité de leur ville.
Souvent, ce sont les jeunes qui souffrent des taux de chômage les plus élevés.
D’ici 2030, trois citadins sur cinq
auront moins de 18 ans.
Si nous n’impliquons pas les jeunes
dans la croissance de nos villes,
si nous ne leur fournissons pas des opportunités,
cette situation d’attente,
cette porte d’accès au terrorisme, à la violence et au crime organisé,
sera l’histoire de nos villes.
Dans ma ville natale, Mogadiscio,
70% des jeunes souffrent du chômage.
70% n’ont pas de travail,
ne vont pas à l’école.
Ils sont là, à ne rien faire.
Je suis retourné à Mogadiscio le mois dernier,
et j’ai visité l’Hôpital Madina,
l’hôpital où je suis né.
Je me souviens être resté debout devant
cet hôpital criblé de balles en pensant,
et si je n’étais jamais parti ?
Si j’avais été forcé de rester
dans cette même situation d’attente ?
Serais-je devenu un terroriste ?
Je ne suis pas vraiment sûr de la réponse.
La raison pour laquelle je me trouvais à Mogadiscio ce mois-là
était en vérité pour organiser
un sommet des jeunes leaders et entrepreneurs.
J’ai réuni quelques 90 jeunes leaders somaliens.
Nous avons réfléchi ensemble à des solutions
aux défis majeurs auxquels leur ville doit faire face.
Un des jeunes hommes dans la salle se nommait Aden.
Il avait obtenu son diplôme de l’université de Mogadiscio.
Mais il n’y avait pas d’emplois, pas d’opportunités.
Je me souviens qu’il m’avait dit,
que parce qu’il était jeune diplômé,
sans emploi et frustré,
il représentait la cible parfaite pour être recruté par al-Shabaab
et d’autres organisations terroristes.
Ils recherchaient des personnes comme lui.
Mais son histoire prit un autre tournant.
A Mogadiscio, le plus grand obstacle
pour aller d’un point A vers un point B c’est les routes.
Vingt-trois ans de guerre civile
ont complètement détruit le réseau routier,
et une motocyclette est le moyen le plus aisé
de se déplacer.
Aden y a vu une opportunité et l’a saisie.
Il a lancé une entreprise de motocyclettes.
Il a commencé à louer ces motos
à des résidents locaux qui ne pouvaient en temps normal se le permettre.
Il a acheté dix motos avec l’aide
de sa famille et de ses amis,
et son rêve est de s’agrandir
en en achetant plusieurs centaines dans les trois années à venir.
Qu’est-ce qui fait que cette histoire est différente ?
Qu’est-ce qui fait que son histoire est différente ?
Je crois que c’est sa capacité à identifier
et à saisir une nouvelle opportunité.
C’est l’esprit d’entreprenariat,
et je pense que l’entreprenariat peut être
le remède le plus puissant contre la situation d’attente.
Il donne aux jeunes les moyens
d’être les créateurs de ces mêmes opportunités
qu’ils recherchent si désespérément.
Et on peut former les jeunes à devenirs des entrepreneurs.
Je vais vous raconter l’histoire d’un autre jeune homme
qui a assisté à une de mes réunions,
Mohamed Mohamoud, un fleuriste.
Il m’aidait à former certains jeunes présents
au sommet de l’entreprenariat
à faire preuve d’un esprit novateur
et apprendre à créer une culture d’entreprenariat.
En fait, il est le premier fleuriste que Mogadiscio ait connu
en plus de 22 ans,
et jusqu’à tout récemment, jusqu’à l’arrivée de Mohamed,
si vous vouliez des fleurs à votre mariage,
il fallait utiliser des bouquets en plastique
expédiés de l’étranger.
Si vous demandiez à quelqu’un
« Qu’elle est la dernière fois où vous avez vu des fleurs fraîches ? »
pour beaucoup de ceux ayant connu la guerre civile,
la réponse serait « Jamais. »
Alors Mohamed vit là une opportunité.
Il fonda une société d’aménagement du paysage et de composition florale.
Il établit une ferme à l’extérieur de Mogadiscio,
où il fit pousser des tulipes et des fleurs de lys,
qui, selon lui, pourraient résister
au dur climat de Mogadiscio.
Et il commença à livrer des fleurs aux mariages,
à aménager des jardins dans les maisons
et les sites commerciaux à travers la ville,
et à présent il travaille sur le projet
du premier jardin public de Mogadiscio en 22 ans.
Il n’y a pas de jardin public à Mogadiscio.
Il veut donc créer un espace où les familles
et les jeunes pourront se retrouver,
et, comme il dit, humer le parfum de ces roses proverbiales.
Au fait, il ne cultive pas de roses car
elles ont besoin de beaucoup trop d’eau.
La première étape est donc d’inspirer les jeunes,
et dans cette salle, la présence de Mohamed
a réellement eu un profond impact sur les jeunes.
Ils n’avaient jamais vraiment pensé à monter leur propre affaire.
Ils avaient pensé à travailler pour une ONG,
à travailler pour le gouvernement,
mais son histoire, son innovation,
a vraiment eu un fort impact sur eux.
Il les a forcé à regarder leur ville
comme une source d’opportunités.
Il leur a permis de croire en leur potentiel d’entrepreneurs,
en leur pouvoir de changer les choses.
A la fin de la journée, ils étaient en mesure
de proposer des solutions innovantes
à certains des défis majeurs auxquels leur ville est confrontée.
Ils ont trouvé des solutions entreprenariales
aux problèmes locaux.
Ainsi, inspirer les jeunes
et créer une culture d’entreprenariat
représente vraiment un grand pas,
mais les jeunes ont besoin de capitaux
pour concrétiser leurs idées.
Ils ont besoin de conseillers et de mentors
pour les guider dans le développement et le lancement de leurs projets.
Donnez aux jeunes les ressources dont ils ont besoin,
accordez-leur le soutien nécessaire pour passer de l’idée à la création,
et vous aurez créé un catalyseur à la croissance urbaine.
Selon moi, l’entreprenariat est plus que le
simple fait de monter une affaire.
C’est avoir un impact sur la société.
Mohamed ne vend pas simplement des fleurs.
Il vend aussi de l’espoir.
Son Peace Park comme il l’appelle,
une fois achevé, va véritablement transformer
le regard des gens sur leur ville.
Aden a engagé des gosses de la rue pour l’aider à louer
et entretenir les motos.
Il leur a ainsi donné l’occasion d’échapper
à la paralysie de la situation d’attente.
Ces jeunes entrepreneurs ont
un immense impact sur leur villes.
Ma suggestion est donc,
transformez les jeunes en entrepreneurs,
incubez et nourrissez leur capacité d’innovation inhérente,
et vous aurez plus d’histoires de fleurs et de Peace Parks
que de voitures piégées et de situations d’attente.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)